[Music]
heaven has abandoned China owing to its
haughtiness and extravagant luxury but I
living in the northern wilderness have
not inordinate passions
I hate luxury and exercise moderation
I have only one coat and one food I eat
the same food and I'm dressed in the
same tatters as my humble herdsmen I
consider my people my children and take
an interest in talented men as if they
were my brothers we always agree in our
principles and we are always united by
mutual affection at military exercises I
am always in the front and in time of
battle and never behind in the space of
seven years I have succeeded in
accomplishing a great work and uniting
the whole world in one Empire I have not
myself distinguished qualities but the
government of the kin is in constant and
therefore heaven assists me to obtain
the throne the sum to south the Hui ho
to the north the here to the east and
the barbarians in the West all together
have acknowledged my supremacy it seems
to me that since the remote time of our
shun you such a vast empire has not been
seen but as my calling is high the
obligations incumbent on me are also
heavy and I fear that in my ruling there
may be something wanting to cross a
river we make boats and rudders likewise
we invite sage men and choose out
assistance for keeping the Empire in
good or
since the time I came to the throne I
have always taken to heart the ruling of
my people but I could not find worthy
men to occupy the places of the 3 and
the 9 with respect to these
circumstances I inquired and heard the
you master have penetrated the truth and
the you walk in the path of right deeply
learned and much experienced you have
much explored the laws your sanctity is
become manifest you have conserved the
rigorous rules of the ancient sages you
are endowed with the eminent talents of
celebrated man for a long time you have
lived in the caverns of the rocks and
have retired from the world but to you
the people who have acquired sanctity
repair like clouds on the path of the
Immortals in innumerable multitude I
knew that after the war you would
continue to live in shantung at the same
place and I was always thinking of you I
know the stories of the returning from
the river way in the same part and of
the invitations in the reader three
times repeated but what shall I do we
are separated by mountains and plains of
great extent and I cannot meet thee I
can only descend from the throne and
stand by the side I have fasted and
washed I have ordered my lieutenant Liu
Chang Liu to prepare an escort and a
cart for
you do not be afraid of a thousand Li I
implore you to move your scented steps
do not think of the extent of the sandy
desert commiserate the people in the
present situation of affairs or have
pity upon me and communicate to me the
means of preserving life I shall serve
thee myself I hope that at least thou
wilt leave me a trifle of thy wisdom say
only one word to me and I shall be happy
in this letter I have briefly expressed
my thoughts and hope that thou will
understand them I also hope that thou
having penetrated the principles of the
great Tao sympathizes with all that is
right and will not resist the wishes of
the people given on the first day of the
fifth month
12:19
[Music]
you